elle est un visage connu à gannat waguih
je savais que tu allais gagner
l'ancien résidant à gaza nahrawess
kaiser pendant notre entrevue à 41 ans
elle devient la première femme à occuper
le poste de grande chef de la communauté
maure
c'était émouvant dit elle de la soirée
d'élection qui s'est tenu samedi son
collègue mike delisle lui même grand
chef de 2004 à 2015 c'est lui son
arrivée au pouvoir la communauté envoyer
le message qu'elle est prête pour du
changement gaza nahrawess qaïda a de
l'expérience fait-il valoir
elle s'implique au sein du conseil mme
horrocks depuis 2009
elle succède à john walton décédé en
août dernier
tu es dirigeante de gannat waguih
pendant près de 30 ans la nouvelle
grande chef a grandi ici même
elle a quitté le nid familial pour jouer
au football professionnel en floride au
début des années 2000 elle a d'ailleurs
obtenu un baccalauréat en psychologie
aux états unis avant de revenir à la
maison
parmi ses priorités elles souhaitent
unir la communauté et apaiser la douleur
causée par la découverte de restes
d'enfants sur les terrains d'anciens
pensionnat autochtone déjà l heure à
briser le plafond de verre et de plus
d'une façon elle est aussi membre de la
communauté lgbt qu plus la première à
devenir grand chef ce qui est important
dit elle ce n'est pas son sexe ni avec
qui elle est mariée mais plutôt sa
contribution à sa communauté ici
sébastien desrosiers radio-canada ghana
wagué